in a way like we just start and
everything startled [ __ ] yeah that's
usually how it happens you know what I
mean oh we're on
we're on yeah what's up everybody it's
date Belles we're live from Hollywood
where Raleigh studios I'm so excited
today because this is like a
thrown-together total episode really
what happened is I realized at the last
second like holy [ __ ] I don't have an
episode for this week I've been so busy
on the road and then I was like you know
what I think would be fun to just get my
girl friends together and do like a
episode where we just shoot the [ __ ]
it's kind of like the view I like it
yeah I feel like we're just gonna we're
gonna talk Tom apart yeah yeah it's on
video I don't know who's on it I don't
know either the Barbara Walters still on
it or no I didn't even know she's alive
okay well that's how far behind I am
Whoopi is right straight yeah yes we'll
be a straight yeah sherry Hershey David
Ansen yeah she did it she did a dead gay
the controversial Wyden affair with her
oh really yeah oh I didn't know that
yeah I do remember that I remember that
whole country yeah I feel like she would
make a great part of my power lesbian
couple that I dream of being no more I
know but if she was she'd be perfect cuz
she's funny and she's eccentric and we'd
be like an interracial couple right and
somebody got the age gap yeah how about
her mics because she is a lesbian I
would love to get Rhonda if you're
watching I would love to yeah I think
she's very share yes Harry
yeah I'm taken yeah Troy her Mara no God
uh I can't do that um well this is gonna
be fun I brought in a bunch of topics
for us to talk about let me introduce
everyone way over there in the far
corner my good friend hilarious comedian
who just came from shooting talking
dirty on Playboy TV erial Kishan Chi
uh and then next to me here you guys
know her cuz I just had her on and also
because she's a very successful actress
and she's stunning and she's hilarious
and now she's doing stand-up as well
which is so fancy Krista Allen everyone
yeah any other face
yeah no you're hilarious you do stand-up
you produce shows and you host one of my
favorite podcasts which everyone should
check out which is called white wine
true crime which is way more popular
than my podcast and is all about people
getting drunk and watching crime TV and
basically being funny and making fun of
it is that yes that is the gist
it's just Kerry Martin everyone hey I
hate to brag but I am almost up to 700
Twitter followers so yeah I know I know
that the whole follower situation is
just it's like we're trying to start
this podcast and we're running late
because we have to snapchat it and
Instagram story--it and Facebook it yeah
Twitter it it's just this too much yeah
the game has changed it's so hard now
it's impossible
basically yeah but by the same token it
could open a lot of doors sure you can
connect with people that you would have
never been exposed to oh my god like you
know what you can do now you can home
you can date like famous athletes but
cuz of social media oh I'm gonna get a
horde of people you know like it used to
be like you would sit and watch the TV
and be like that guy is so hot I wish
there was some way I could get in [ __ ]
that's true now you can just slide a lie
- yeah yes studia let's only meet
everybody hide a Twitter is your tender
Twitter is my dad is it sweater is the
tinder and I don't even I'm like I don't
even play like I'm like a guy like this
is the DM I send guys this it's the same
to all of them they're probably having
were probably watching his life yeah I
go ID on them and I just go why are we
not dating oh my god that's such a guy
thing to say that's it that's good yeah
and then I wait game have you been all
my life feeling if I did that guy he'd
be like because you don't have enough
followers
later get out of here kid
well it's funny because anytime I D I'm
a guy the next thing I do is go on that
lat like that social media platform if
it was Instagram or Twitter and make
sure that my last photo was a really hot
one and if it wasn't I add one real good
yeah like I can't let him see me looking
like I do on stage I know I love that
kate has an arsenal of the hottest
photos just to go ready ready to rock
and roll
thank you yeah I use those to apologize
when I have stupid the good secret
weapon now it really like it I should
yeah I'm not that smart I don't have yes
you are I don't have it you're smart
because you don't yeah here's what I do
it when I go on the road for comedy I'm
so bored during the day that I just take
hot photos in my room I have nothing
better to do I just take off photos and
I just save them up and if I don't have
anywhere to send them to I just save
them up so on a rainy day when I need to
apologize to someone even girlfriends
carry got numb yeah I don't mind him I'm
beyond it and I God just please piss me
off so I can get one that's all I cause
when I between men I sent him two girls
that's what we do right now you send
each other a bunch yeah cuz when I'm
like when we've been working out I
haven't eaten a carbon my T&E months
somebody's got to appreciate that I can
I can relate to that I need to start
taking pictures okay my mom to your
Center to your mom
yeah I've done that yeah my mom is like
oh okay why are you sending me you don't
understand I mean I've been there I'm
not gonna lie I had a question it went
away
well whatever we'll get back to it I
want to open with this okay I don't know
if Ariel yes you know about this Christa
doesn't carry does I had the best date
fail at the best date fail story and we
need to address it so this just just
happened I've been talking this guy for
a while
we met on Twitter we have been talking
for probably about seven months or so
but just talking just talking and we've
been out on three dates only three right
he doesn't live in LA so it's like a
long-distance e thing but whenever he
comes here we always go out we have not
had sex
and the first date actually wasn't even
that into him I talked about him on this
podcast and I was like and he told me to
vote for Trump and he like sent back my
diet coat because it wasn't wasn't good
enough for me and he didn't think I
should drink aspartame or whatever so I
wasn't yet he's voting for Trump
I know Trump like I know right so um but
we but then I went out with him again
because we kissed and we had great
chemistry and he's SuperDuper hot and I
thought I'd give him a second chance
second date way way better very cool
third date he invited me out with his
buddies he was in town he was out with a
bunch of buddies he invited me and I got
to see that he's funny and cool and we
kind of hit it off so now on the third
date we kind of make out and I'm like oh
when we hook up it's gonna be it's gonna
be hot
fireworks gonna be fireworks it's gonna
be amazing okay this guy by the way
looks like an Adonis
he's a ten I think I know who you're
talking to pro athlete yes yes yes I
remember it doesn't narrow it down
usually no it does if this was hanging
it was starting the other yeah no I do
Kenny buddy anybody um so okay so what
happened is I was just in Florida doing
stand-up and I was texting with him and
I was like we should hang out soon again
when are you coming back to LA and he
said not for a while but I'm gonna be in
China for a month
why don't you come visit me in China and
I was like okay yeah maybe maybe I will
you know he's like my treat figure out
the visa
I'll get the plane ticket you're coming
to China and I'm like great
so I start telling my friend who's on
the road with me and and he's like oh my
god I'm so excited I love that guy I'm a
huge fan he goes but the thing is I'm
pretty sure he has a girlfriend so I do
a little stalking as well you do
diligence yeah due diligence and it
turns out I see a photo kind of deep on
his Instagram of a girl holding a baby
so I'm like when Kate tells me this
story she's like yeah I got that picture
and he's with a girl and guess what
she's holding it Hey huh I don't know
anything like it feels like a leading
question child Eric she was gasps Hayley
yeah I'm getting another view I would
have been like dildo by the way the
second time I've been involved with a
guy and found out he has a girl with the
baby like so okay but here's the thing
is that this isn't even the best part of
the story I find out he has this girl so
I text him and I go hey this is a little
awkward to ask because the pictures like
five months old I'm like maybe they
broke up I don't know you know we have
been talk we've only been out a few
times so I messaged him and I say hey um
this is a little awkward to ask but
before I go spend money on a visa do you
have a girlfriend
and he wrote back yes I do
but it's an open relationship she knows
I see other people although she doesn't
like it I don't think he felt the need
to that is buddy oh I guess he was like
don't contact her she's not gonna be
cool hey I mean I wonder if that's right
through it and he thought I would
message her oh my maybe you could be
right I mean yeah I should know I think
we should message her now
threesome question mark
I summon China I didn't turn a picture
of your head between her
the face of the baby and like a snapchat
the one would like the dog tongue coming
out oh my god would be here really bad
oh so it gets better so then um he said
that and then I wrote back and I said
well listen I appreciate your honesty
but the thing is I'm not looking for
that type of situation I thought you
were single so that's that and then he
wrote back well we're both adults and
everyone has some luggage
what is your baggage and I wrote back I
think you mean baggage she really wants
you to take this trip he's really a
luggage he's you know he's like Oh carry
on and carry on keeping the theme going
a trap it has some luggage he's not
American that's nothing I got American
Russian but still I'm like um I mean a
girlfriend and a baby is not baggage
it's a girlfriend why don't you take
your luggage with you to China you know
what I mean like why are you inviting me
well he probably wants like instead of a
hard case luggage he wants like it's
like something monogrammed duffel bag
yeah we're like varied luggage no G
luggage okay here's my question and why
I wanted to bring this up because then
he says to me well we've been out now a
few times why didn't you ask me right
away and I was like to be honest with
you I just assumed if you were trying to
date me that you were single
right I mean of course you're by dating
people you're an athlete you're ha of
course you have women but I just assumed
that you didn't have a serious situation
or why would you ask me I wouldn't even
be I wouldn't be hitting people up to
date or inviting people overseas if I
was with someone so the question is do
we really have to ask this question when
you meet a guy do you need to ask right
away I don't but I don't date your
caliber guy is like I date a guy
was one time not too long ago I dated a
guy who worked at Trader Joe's and I
think mom would come over and watch TV
honey no that's good that's it it's very
anti-climatic story I'm just saying
grown from a good point
I don't date always these kinds of guys
I've dated plenty of losers what are her
two types losers and I'm sorry today or
did I not like totally fall for a porn
act well yeah okay I don't say elite you
know upper echelon people all the time
but you're attracted to a certain type
of guy which is the douchey kind of guy
that has a relationship and a kid hi
Rick Tigers baseball cap call Amy
describe him Nicole another one the porn
guy
Nicole Amy said he look like you should
be changing tires someone she goes if I
saw you out with them I'd be like Kate
why did you bring your mechanic in the
comic okay buddy but but here's the
thing is that like for me this has
happened multiple times so yes obviously
I am attracted to guys that are
unavailable and we know that we must
we've established that unavailable more
than douchey let's write let's just
establish that unavailable you're also
like a mix of the two yeah it kinda is I
just wanted to make her feel better
thank you Ariel's died of our little
real honesty yeah question is like okay
so what is an appropriate thing to act
like if I met a guy on say a dating app
is it safe to assume he's single or do I
need to say do you have a girlfriend
before Twitter isn't known for most of
us what but yeah if you're if you if
you're pursuing someone in any like
nonplatonic way you say by the way I
have a girlfriend like right off the bat
yeah I have a girlfriend and we have an
open really and a baby ship and a baby
and some luggage that many guys would be
that open right off the bat but you know
what I mean so sure I mean I think you
have to wait until you see if you have
chemistry if you like him whatever then
he asks you to China and maybe that's a
good time but he wouldn't
you do not know but here's the best
there would have been in China right and
he would have been like hold on it's my
girlfriend and baby or like maybe you
ought to showed up to his hotel room and
there would have been a baby and a girl
on there and he was like can you baby so
I would yeah you don't know or just a
crib and you're like you're into some
kinky [ __ ] yeah did some diapers really
and they were okay I mean but the thing
is that even after I said you know and
by the way I have to say this I'm a
little proud of myself because the porn
guy and this guy and all of this has
made me realize I actually think I want
something more like all this time I've
been like I'm cool with casual I'm
casual I'm just cat I don't want a
relationship and but the truth is I'm
tired of finding out oh I'm the side
chick I'm just a girl you're trying to
bang I'm actually at a place where I'm I
said to him I go here's the thing if I
come to China let's just say we have a
fantastic time and I really like you now
I can't have anything real with you
because you have a girlfriend so I'm the
only person who stands to get hurt yeah
I'm really proud of you about this this
has been a long-running thing and this
is good and you've been doing this a
[ __ ] I like it I like it
she's really not fun little deaf ones
growing that one it is but but the thing
is he didn't answer that text and now
next day he sent me a photo of
gluten-free corn dog okay very good
aroma laughs like he's probably like I
don't know why corn dog is gluten-free
yes
that's my mom come to China no more dogs
and she worked for the girl that he had
the baby with she liked the gluten-free
corn dog so I had tweeted a joke about
gluten-free corn dogs and a photo and he
was sending me my own photo but the
point is how like a man he's not
originally there so okay cool just
sending you like that's like somebody
sending me a screenshot of something
that I like you posted yeah guys do that
to me they don't do that to you
yeah they do yeah it's so weird yeah I'm
like I know what this looks like
thank you wait I don't understand this
why would you say send you dad you
like I'll post a tweet and then a guy
what cuz this is what they do they know
like oh you have 200,000 like Chrissy
you have 200 thousand Twitter followers
so the guy's not going to reply to the
tweet he's gonna scream grab your tweet
text it to you like ha ha ha know that
okay I see what your tomato you know
okay right yeah okay I've seen that
before but so this this this is what do
you reply to the corn dog can we just
call him corn dog I like that you're a
bloody corn dog I wrote back lol with a
question mark and then in a row back
that looks did you buy it like he
basically shifted into the end result oh
he's trying to pretend that you never
had this conversation
yeah what is it that way you should have
said no thank you sir I will get a corn
dog that is unattached like I'm not
gonna get mine from Costco I'll get it
from corn dog let me stick singl corn
dog yeah one that I can corn dog emoji
yeah I don't know it's not the
conversation I thought we were gonna
have today I know honest we spend an
exorbitant amount of time on corn dog
corn dogs well I just because this is an
important topic yeah okay because a I
would just like to say to all the men
watching please if you have a girlfriend
just tell us tell us or be better idea
don't date us well I got on a first date
with a guy and who was like I was like
oh he's got like the profile of someone
like he was like famous in the 90s for a
minute and then he's not anymore and
he's like gained a lot of weight not
that that's like part of the thing but
he's gained a lot of weight like I was I
was Greco oh yeah sure yeah yeah I would
I would have got I would have given him
a second date
this was like a former singer I'm okay
like yeah you hit wonder anyway I did
he's like yeah
I'll tell you after I mean you hate
about him though I knew it so he's never
know uh he um he was like do you you
know I have these friends that are
polyamorous and he was like feeling
analyst yeah it's British polyamorous so
you're trying to get you a new line item
right away trying to like feel me out
and I was like oh I'm like no that's not
really my thing like good for them but I
feel like that's like a low self-esteem
girl thing to do you know what I mean
like I've seen these videos will like on
like they do documentaries on these
polyamorous couples right and I got to
get through this that's just what's the
song that he sing I gotta get to I got
anything you just gave away what I like
she's like you guys I'm not gonna tell
you who it is but I'm [ __ ] this boxer
who bid a guy's ear
not bad I mean he wasn't that but anyway
well my boy so he is he's trying to like
throw it like feelers out and I was like
oh that's cool not my thing and then I'm
starting to like pick up what he's doing
you know I was like oh he's trying to
fill me out see this date is like a
desert like why couldn't you tell me
beforehand this is a tinder date right
well he wanted was to get you involved
in some kind of origin why maybe part of
his well you wanted me part of his like
hair I'm like he's like you know I'm
Holly amorous and I just want you need
support of my life and that's what I do
and I was like the string up guy up cup
guy just be upfront like but I
appreciated that at least he told me on
the first day right yeah I was like
alright okay I can walk away from this
date and be like this was entertaining I
have a seven minute bit about you now
thank you
cuz he did karaoke and steady dressing
his on things we were so we would he
sing his own song no he didn't oh yeah
I'll tell you what he did we go to we go
to this place and he everyone there
knows him and and so like he's like a
regular woman like it was like this
cheers you know there's a handful I know
it's Tiki it's a tiki bar in North
Hollywood and and we go in there
everyone's like hey hey everyone knows
it I'm like okay he's like oh my god
it's karaoke night I had no idea
leach I need to know the guys name just
say is the OL Bedingfield okay thank ok
alright and so and he didn't know that I
knew who he was I just googled him to
make sure he wasn't married before our
date right oh it's that former singer
all right fine
yeah and and then he's like I didn't
know it was karaoke no do you want to go
somewhere else I'm like no there's
nowhere else around here you're know is
karaoke not your regular like this is
like cheers frog each other there for
the same reason play was in the corner
doing shock like it was yeah he took you
there for the same reason that I invite
guys to comedy clubs to sunshine yes
it's like well it's his comfort zone
everyone there knows him he looks cool
I invite guys to comedy clubs because I
know also like if it's not going well
there's a hundred people there I know
that I can kind of ditch em and start
talking to other people and he'll take
the hint like it's just that's what I do
with first dates I'm like come meet me
here at the improv after my set we'll
have a drink and then if it's not going
well I can just be like
oh I gotta get going ever early morning
and then I wait for him to leave and
they come back into the improv and just
hang out he probably he probably thought
his charm would win you over and you'd
be like I would love to have a threesome
with you in your heart I mean probably
here obably thought was you know dating
face to face this is just like strip
club guy it took me a minute to register
it's exactly like a club guy did this um
yeah it's a guy his name is Sean we can
give him a first name his name was Sean
do we say he was a pro athlete or no
well thank you Carrie there's a lot of
Sean's that are pro athletes right say
what's good MA leann rimes in a delicate
boiler yeah yes he's a cricket player I
love [ __ ] cricket players so this is
the first guy ever deemed in my life I
was like he's so beautiful I have to
have him that was like my thoughts OID
um dim and how he said was that your
intro line no it was why don't we dating
that's my go-to line with every DM did I
ever send why aren't we dating so he's
like I don't know we probably should fix
that you know and then we and then we
went out and then we went out on one
date and we had a great time but I
should have known the first night
because you know what to be full
disclosure with it we got we started
making out outside the club first night
amazing chemistry called an uber - oh
burrs cuz he was going out and I had to
go home because I had [ __ ] in the
morning so he called - tubers but mine
came first we got in the back of my over
with me and we started like hooking up a
little bit in the back of the uber and
it was like how awkward for that driver
right now right no in the 90s or they
could like put support you hear all the
hook-up he would make College slob
[ __ ] we're making out but with Mo no
heavy betting the point is this I was
like you know what [ __ ] my morning let's
go back to your place and he was like I
can't I'm going to meet up with Dada
he's like I'll save it anyway it'll be
more special you know I'm like fine then
the next day he invites me out carries
with me what saddle ranch hanging out
the guy text me like yo come meet up
we're like where are you he's like I'm
at games and dames we're like what's
that he's like it
sports bar we get there it's a strip
club okay we get is it sporty it's a
yeah are they wearing jersey yes Wow
well the waitresses or waitresses our
referee strikes okay well but we get in
there and he's got like he's trying to
hook up with like 12 girls he invited
all these girls I wasn't the only one oh
there was I everybody was there so yeah
like the bachelor basically yeah it was
and he would come around and he talked
to you for a minute and he kind of like
kiss on you be like I'm so gross he was
so gross that's gross
I know but wouldn't it be funny if
instead of offering like roses like The
Bachelor he offered you like dollar
bills that's where I came in
well you know what this jungle will you
accept this crumpled doll okay ring
woman me to this place and then I'm like
I'm like Carrie what do we do is she
like what to tell him what you did well
first off were sitting there he's like
I'm gonna get around a shot so I'm like
okay he's got pro-athlete money I'm not
used to this like I'm gonna be great
it's gonna be top-shelf milk I was
fireball this got around oh I still
drank it but not only that but what did
he what else did he have to drink at his
table pitchers of Budweiser it wasn't
even like good liquor
yeah dad then I was like oh I was like
where are we because we had over there
oh and he's like we're in envel and I
was like what
he's the quarren i'ma go yeah and I was
like is that in Carson like are we like
I forgot of you I went way out of town
wherever he could take everybody out of
toilet the n-word yeah yes oh my god
he's around and I can't ya know I
thought there was something called envel
that near Inglewood Daniel so then I was
like I don't really know what's going on
I would ensure he was kind of like one
toe in the water one not because you
didn't know what was going on you're
getting the college girl used because I
tried to leave once and then and then I
was like hey you know what this isn't
really my scene I'm gonna go which I
should have done as soon as I walked in
by the way coincidentally our friend was
the strip club DJ a guy a comic that
were friends with he was there that
yes yeah yeah the best part ish he said
my name a couple times on the thing I'm
not talking to your athlete guy so I was
like I don't know what to do so I had
like 30 dollars in cash so I changed it
into ones and I put him up on the rail I
support him like nobody it wasn't there
like a squad right so no guys on the
rail but me she was the only girl
watching a stripper person period
watching the troopers so they would come
over and I was like oh my god when you'd
to the split like that was like the best
dance mom I'd give him how easy
coordination right it really was
she was like excellent arabesque that
was beautiful she's holding them
scorecards oh dang
all right everyone I support you I
support you I sure just left and my
self-esteem has come a long way since
then because I have to admit like I had
no self-esteem out of my marriage and
Sean was that's what probably at least a
year and a half ago I've gotten better
but like what about any of the other
girl eh uh yeah well the other girls
were getting real you know they were
they get interest we were jealous they
didn't like it yeah and then he would
come to me and he'd be like babe we're
gonna leave soon just me and you I'm
trying to hook up with these girls just
gonna be me and you did it and I was
like okay and I'd stay and then I'd
watch but the the final straw for me was
there was like a waitress that came up
that worked there and she was wearing
his Jersey she was wearing his and she
won and he was like no our battle but he
like she was her number like right in
front of me and I was like [ __ ] this and
I left and I just sent him attacks like
sorry not my scene have a good night and
I left and then Ike he did blow me up
for a while cuz that's what they do when
you finally like [ __ ] you yeah that's
what it looks so good I know it's so
gross but then the thing is he's just so
hot that you know when someone so high
can I ever be that I know that no
hotness I could ever known okay good huh
yeah
never yeah um my night it was fine okay
to be fair to me though like I I did not
go home with him that night
the next day I you know you've come a
long way come a long way along with if
that were to happen today you would
probably only stay for 45 minutes that
happened today as soon as I saw it we
got there and it was a strip club okay I
thought not again strip clubs I would go
in and hang if it was like him and his
boys and him but the minute I saw other
girls and what was up I'd be like [ __ ]
you and leave immediately I'm trying to
be the girl that I give such great
advice I want to start being the girl
that I tell you guys to be maybe stop
leading with why aren't we dating
yeah well maybe try something a little
bit more like hey hey it's like I don't
know I'm new pickup line looks like that
what's a medium rowdy in a few other way
do you have anyone that you wanted yeah
yeah um I could find somebody yeah all
right let's think of a new pickup line a
new intro I don't think I want to date
famous anyone famous ever again ever
again never again your guy from her bet
the plugin oh yeah okay yeah I don't
want that guy I don't want anyone oh we
can practice on him in show business I
want a normal well he's not - you're
lucky well you want a normal guy I want
a regular guy okay cool no like maybe
maybe like somebody who just got out of
jail
so he has to have some kind of bad boy
yeah wallet CrossFit and just a guy
there yeah great I have the body type
you like they wear it side words
sideways hat there they're paleo you
guys can eat they probably have thrown
jewelry and Opilio no you horrible what
are those I can't lead Eugene the true
religion jeans does that better
oh and shirt what are you talking about
I don't want you I like know you would
date a guy with true religion jeans and
an affliction t-shirt ah oh I have
listen can I ask her the next question
this is going great by day I know I got
a big an [ __ ] all a gang up on Kate
my poor daddy love mm it's not a tough
love broadcast I'm happy to look like
the crazy one here because I know in my
heart that all of you are equal
Lia's craziest absolutely actually carry
yes I have to kind of rants when I do
come and glued one is alcohol-induced
the other is ambien and deuce yeah when
is happened we tell the ambien story or
you not want to call it about the guy
that came over and you couldn't remember
anything
oh I mean that's kind of the story tell
it what did you have ambiens well to
come on tell the story you booty called
a guy and then you you'd already taken
ambien what happened is I didn't think
is gonna come over yeah she took the
ambien and then she sent the booty call
thinking he'd say no and then he said
yes and then I remembered pieces like I
date-rape myself before and he came over
essentially that's amazing so it's like
I kind of remember letting him in a kind
of remember us talking and then he was
gone like I was like it was like that
movie memento or some great it's like
putting pieces together the next day you
know what happed I don't and I think I'm
gonna go to my grave that way we don't
talk she doesn't know what happened and
then the next day she sent him a text
like hey like kind of a good season to
say hey um I it's embarrassing but I
kind of took an ambien before you came
over and I just I hope I didn't say
anything weird or I don't know what my
butthole really hurt I was mentally now
elbow
and he didn't answer so she does that
she's like did I do something wrong he
didn't answer she doesn't know was it
someone I know you know what you
probably just passed out and he was the
IV I you know her speed and I fell
asleep or I worked out much of a mess
like David Hasselhoff without the burger
oh yeah and he just walked right back
out maybe I'm thinking - were you
drinking an ambien typically yeah that's
how it goes
I love it I mean hand in hand we've all
done here the reason I love Carrie so
much full disclosure is because I am a
psycho when it comes to texting and I
talk about it on stage I mean I have a
problem it's like I will send a guy
17,000 text messages and I'm so bipolar
about it because I send it and I mean it
I mean it okay in the moment I mean it
I'm like it's over I hate you or I love
you or I want to [ __ ] the [ __ ] out
whatever it is I send it and then when
he does when I see he read it and he
doesn't answer right away I start to
psychoanalyze ya everything about it and
think maybe it was wrong and then I'll
send another one like backpedaling and
then I'll see that he read that and
doesn't answer and then I get angry that
he's insensitive so I send another one
angry and I just keep going until I
can't stop anymore
and the only person I know who does this
also is Cara big with a worse support
system for each other the world we don't
give up on each other which I like with
my two addicts that instead of being
like a sponsor for each other is like
it's fine keep smoking it's over like no
that's totally normal I'm like yeah I
told this joint you said that like
somebody should confiscate this I think
so
someone needs to make an app okay
there'd be talked about sweat there's
like a google there was like a drunk
texting yeah there is yeah I have the
drunk text app and but see it only works
if you're drunk I send these sober yeah
you're sober don't you guys worse on my
own deaf you should do long division to
like
there needs to be a text or an app that
works like this like I basically put
Christa in charge yes my phone somehow
she can intercept it gives her custody
of that phone number so like I can for
instance give her like you know Max's
phone number and then any time I try to
text to max it yeah go to Christa yeah
he goes [ __ ] no you ain't sending that
and say killing me like that we got this
right yeah talk about yappin yeah I
think that's such a great idea ban it or
should we if you've been drinking then
maybe when you text somebody all that
they get is a picture of a corndog long
as it's gluten-free and all right well
here's here's a question that I want to
bring up because I'm really curious and
I wish we had guys to ask this too but
so now that I've realized that I
actually want more I don't wanna be a
tired of being a side chick I don't know
how I always end up a side chick I just
found out a guy that I dated for a year
that I was in love with I just found out
he had a girlfriend like the whole time
we're dating
I just found that out guys brutal so
even when I don't know a comic you know
to soy even when I don't know that I'm a
side chick I'm always a side chick and I
don't know what it is about me that says
side chick which I should figure out but
what I want to know is this when you
tell a guy how far into dating do you
tell a guy I'm looking for something
real without scaring them off because I
feel like if you if you don't tell them
right up front and they're just looking
for like a casual like a good time like
a fling then you you know you might end
up getting hurt is it better to put it
right out no you should put it right
that right out there yeah and look if
they're going to get scared off they're
not the guy that's not gonna make you a
side check for serial right also also
it's not yes you're not you're not
saying I want
like you're not don't don't say I want
you to propose to me tomorrow I don't
should say oh I am NOT interested in a
booty call I want to get to know you as
a human being because you usually have
relationships with human beings not like
other genitals you know what I mean like
if I wanted to get to know a guy I
wouldn't have sex with him right away
because right then I would confuse like
liking having sex with him with and I
only say that because I've been there so
many gay Jew I to God yeah I like all I
did was like like having sex with him
like as human beings I hated them but
that's cuz I had touched them too soon
yes wait yeah then you get to know when
a ring on it
yeah of course we you know of course I
got it like that's just like you know it
was like such a badass [ __ ] though like
Ariel is literally that girl that's like
she really doesn't give a [ __ ] if the
guy comes or goes so if the guy isn't
giving her everything she wants she's
like [ __ ] you bye
and that's why you guys chase her I say
that but then I always go back so then
it goes from them being like like don't
go to like okay and it's like no wait
what do you mean okay yeah but you have
to know there's like another one around
the corner there alright anyone where
you came from it thank you
or to find when you have that chemistry
with you're gonna find chemistry no
cameras you can probably find chemistry
with most people most you have with most
guys cuz you have this great personality
and you'll connect with people and it's
awesome the guy that you tell the guy
that you're like look I don't want to be
a side chick I don't want it I don't
want to do this I want a relationship
with somebody are you into that and he
goes yeah I'm looking for a girlfriend
you say cool if he doesn't want that
then he's not that guy maybe you'll
still go I want I just want to [ __ ] you
anyway it's cool maybe I'll be your side
chick you could go there okay but you
could but I'm just saying like lism you
don't have to be scared of that stuff I
am doesn't mean your desk yeah I think
what your your guys gonna misinterpret
it as I'm desperate more like I do I'm a
grown-ass woman strength you know what
you haven't is that like you're being a
floozy kind of
whatever did I do lose II know but I
know I closed it I know what you mean a
fool easy yeah damn floozy I mean I am
afraid though of cuz that's the thing is
this I do want something real but I also
want something awesome that's real I
don't want just any guy that's like I'll
make you my girl like I could have that
I know that but I so if I tell a guy I'm
looking for something real it doesn't
mean I want it with you and I'm afraid
right I'm afraid they're gonna
immediately go great let's do this well
then you need to say I want to get to
know you and see if this is like if this
is gonna work out you've been doing
pretty good with this by the way except
for the one guy I've been doing pretty
well right but like you're like you know
you're getting there you're building it
up you you know what you want you know
what you don't want which is really
important that's the first step come on
that's the first step Kate Zoey there's
11 more stubs
yeah but it's ok rolltalk or this one
yeah how did it be 11 more my god oh my
point is like a 12-step program
alright my stats why do you say that cuz
today my roommate Eric my Eric Myers
lives with me he's very funny comedian
he was like Kate I think you should go
to love and sex addicts anonymous to
help you or how you get addicted to men
we definitely are love addict yeah
that's what he said and I was like well
maybe they can pick up carry on the way
I feel like you guys are dire and just
pick up that's a goodie I think guys go
you yeah yeah yeah I'd like to go there
all I'm gonna do is find a bunch of
damaged guys that I'm crazy about no I
think you knows this well but Eric Oh
Eric said the most amazing thing today
and people can take this and use it Eric
you totally inspired me it's this great
advice yeah Eric said to me he goes Kate
here's the thing you need to take guys
that are bad for you cuz I fall for guys
that are bad for me I really do
he goes you need to take guys that are
bad for you and treat them the way I
treat alcohol which is this they ruin my
life they get in the way of my
creativity they get in the way my
business if the guy is bad for you he
goes I can't drink casually I can't have
one drink without falling off the wagon
I will fall off the wagon
he goes you can't take a guy that's
toxic and be like well I'll just [ __ ]
him everyone's wrong I'll just see him
every once in I can yeah he's like that
is like a sip of alcohol it's just gonna
start the spiral so you need to remove
them from your life completely and no
one's ever put it in those terms for me
before where I was like wow it really is
interesting it is as bad for you it's
like gluten and sugar the two things you
don't eat I know you should treat them
like gluten and sugar you know what it
yeah be the change that our names in
your phone one yeah think of it as it
think of it as like a really fattening
chocolate cupcake and even if you have a
few little nibbles you're still gonna
feel like [ __ ] about yourself it's true
well and here you're loaded here's what
I started thinking and this is what I
want to know I have a new plan I am so
savvy about my career okay dad like if
someone [ __ ] with my career I'm like
you're gone
like gone immediately and I think women
when it comes to men we get emotional
but the truth is at the end of the day
if you treat men the way you treat your
career with logic and with like with
like smart you know right brain thinking
I think that we would all do better with
a man right so my new plan is to treat
every man like a stock option like I'm
gonna treat him like business it's
business are you yeah I do that yeah
I'll talk to you tonight see how this
plays out is I might want anyone hey
honestly can we do a 30-day challenge on
this oh my god that would be great
we've tried I there was 30 days to pay
just 30 Dottie okay let's set the
parameters okay 30 days okay 30 days I
can't text anyone that we know is bad
for me which we can name that we know
who they are we know hey there no
texting no content no keys no contact
with somebody who with those guys made
you feel not good about yourself all
right I meet somebody within the next 30
days then your dentist challenge too no
yeah no I thought you were already
taking this child no sex after tonight
no I planned okay but no success for
tonight have trance tonight but after
today
I'll make it a 29 day challenge let's
start tomorrow all right fine no thanks
tonight I want I want it use a vibrator
this comes out on Friday no sex no sex
okay 30 the no sex for 30 all right okay
putting the Gary yeah it's I don't see
you pulling out a phone right putting no
but in put in the parameters what are
the challenges what okay we here
okay dad we want listen we want you to
find okay listen
hello you aren't you Kay you're not
gonna look for men to validate you right
you need to like find ways about it
yourself right it's like send us your
nudes oh yes no sending of nudes okay no
sending nudes to any guy no posting
nudes either no picking up guys it's
like sending it to like eight guys I
don't post nude okay no posting no ha
well she photos no no hot sex for 30
days just 13 80 count um nothing are you
liking your tongue out I think you guys
you mean sending two guys right or just
hosting anywhere no because when came
posta it's like she's communicating with
a guy I have that I have the bad guys
blocked on my social media typically
it's her but if she's gonna show
anything thank you Gary and that way I
get something but offers okay so the
30-day challenge is no sex no ending
nudes no sending no posting something
for someone's attention unless it's
actually a career thing okay say that
right yeah okay let's see if you do a
job or something that okay okay never
think is there a zero no cook you can
read is there a book and an
inspirational book you can read it feels
like work yeah not a good idea
I probably good idea I don't think ever
something like we're gonna drive addicts
anonymous
oh I already read why men love [ __ ]
I'm not the right one to read I read
that's a gamey one I read a book about
uh I read a book called women who love
too much about that is a good one right
yeah but I think you need something
that's just like gonna show you that you
don't he's I got it I to yourself I got
it
Whaley motivation denied what does that
mean Ely um whatever man
motivation daddy what is the thing where
you concentrate on one annotation
meditation okay
yeah meditate daily meditation a daily
meditation you are good yes good but
also what about getting 10 well writing
10 things you're grateful for every
morning you get you in a good mindset a
maza t'v inspirational mind and I've had
things that you love about yourself yes
yeah it's a lot every day 10 new things
no it doesn't have to be ten new things
okay just jog your memory yeah ten
things that you love about yourself you
vary from day to day yeah okay but are
you housing things by the end of the
challenge that's not that bad so far yes
I like this that's like you wake up in
the morning you write your gratitude
list you close your eyes for what do
Tenma don't dotar raising that having an
advantage right meditation do gratitude
list you send it out you have to be a
counter guy to send it to each other
yeah you have la send them to us also a
daily workout because I think when you
work out good for your confidence and
there keeps you inspired and aren't you
happy okay so that what about this what
about masturbating that's fine yeah
great thank you sure masturbate see I
don't know I think you should not
masturbate do you know why because I
think about the bad guys oh okay well my
different way to masturbate alright
another channel are you Carrie why
didn't you think about something else
think about somebody you haven't been
with or I don't know what's corn or some
I can't
yeah
can't do that alright well your pan is a
family show that you could masturbate to
masturbate to criminal body who would
masturbate to the NOPA yeah she never
look at Ryan Gosling the same Ghaziabad
and Reynolds touch [ __ ] the Rhine runnel
no I said that it was rather I would
[ __ ] Ryan that's by the way Ryan if
you're watching I'm not interested in
any actor man there's are not any and
tiny and they're it's like they're like
a little too like they talk about their
feelings why have you did a lot of
arctor yeah yeah I mean I'm dated a few
but then I'm like oh make this end why
is he so dramatic that's just too much
like yeah like one of us has have a
penis one one just one but in Hollywood
yeah I do be an so there's gonna be no
dating for this whole 30-day no date can
we interaction oh you could let's just
let you that can become like and try to
come from a feminine energy of a place
of that is great you guys are awesome
okay wait I have I need more help
okay wait hold on here's another
question I really do want to date guys
and make them wait until I want to have
sex with them for a long time because
you know why a couple of my friends my
guy friends I could see myself like
falling in love with because I love them
so much we've been friends for so long
and if we did have sex and it was
awesome it would be like love right
right
so what how do you tell a guy that
you're like you're deciding to make
people wait now how do you tell them so
that they don't think you're not into
them if you don't [ __ ] them and
everybody I want to get to know you as a
person before we introduce anything
physical but everyone has sex by the
third or fourth date now how do you not
necessarily
I've waited like six or seven what's the
longest you've made a guy wait I don't I
don't know maybe a couple of weeks maybe
that's it
probably there's nothing but I'm there
always long-term relationships like I
know like I will know and then I'll do
it I've never see crystal - one-night
stands in most of life yeah
okay so if I I've only had that's righti
- now what I had one recently yours keep
going I mean I'm talking does it count
as a one-night stand if they text you
after to hang out more but you just
never end up hanging out I don't know I
don't either
care I mean if you have sex on like the
first time you meet him that's a
one-night stand
otherwise it's just casual sex yeah
right if it had - casual sex I should
say right but you're the girl like I'm
looking at where this Star Wars she's
got out of Kmart hat and so we're sure
she's a girl guys are like that's
relationship material I'm the girl guys
are like it I got a baby mama bug her on
the side well you know what I can't tell
you how many married men opit on me and
I'm still like really yeah what do you
think it is I don't know I think I've
like the mistress look it's the heavy
eyeliner well I mean this is like the
fresh from Playboy yeah but like I like
married men all the time Carrie what
about you as far as you get hit on by a
lot of guys that you find out have
girlfriends or husband yeah husband it's
definitely why because that would be why
we don't drink on each other by the way
everyone's drinking today except her so
me yeah I don't drink oh let's see
that's why you wife er up that's why why
yeah you're right yeah buddy
don't you want to get married yeah let's
get married you're really hitting it off
do it really we're kind of they really
are it can be dated one of us would end
up like Tia left eye and like burn the
other ones house down like Lisa left eye
Lopes look that would be me I'd end up
with a black eye Julia what do I take
you back I would burn a guy's house down
dude chicken I tell you Mary Ellen and
Portia Hey right Jen's not here today my
good friend turned serger which I'm sad
about was she was I know
and uh jen is the [ __ ] best wingwoman
ever like James like this like this this
porn guy okay I've had to keep her away
from this guy because Jen gets so mad
it's like it's happening to her guys
[ __ ] with me like just last night Jen is
like hey
Cody's out of town I have his truck for
the week let's go [ __ ] trash this
guy's out
go yeah jen is like you want to go on a
covert operation we could spy on her sit
outside his house and we can see what am
i jegg down she's like give me his
number I'm gonna calm right now and time
to leave you look like Jenna's crazy but
I think every girl needs to have a
friend that cares about them that right
they're like I will [ __ ] a dude up for
you like that right I wanna [ __ ] I
want to [ __ ] a guy up for somebody who
you got who you got care can I cut a guy
for you can I go there yeah
I would love to I already called the guy
Carrie's been seeing a guy that's been
[ __ ] with her feelings and I swear to
God on the way here I almost called him
because I know him I almost called him
on the phone to be like yo you need to
[ __ ] stop [ __ ] with my girl like I
I want to do that what would you do if I
did that um would you mind
ah I mean I think I've already done
irreparable damage so I don't know what
else you can add to the fire is this
some who I know yeah okay well I just
want to know like if that's a good move
because I don't think that's a good move
because here's women no I don't think
it's I think that I think that you
should give a guy just as much attention
as he gives you yeah you know like right
I think that every girl does the same we
go on a date with guy and then you start
imagining your future with him and or or
you know you like when he's gone you're
like oh yeah and like that it's end and
it's not healthy but there's a lot of
mine where we'll hang out and I don't
know what it's gonna be and then after
we hang out for a little bit they're
just like yeah we're just having fun
right and it's like oh yeah and I want
to be the cool girl like I don't know
what I should be I know and I understand
yeah you know what just about changing
habits I guess I dated a guy about
loving yourself yeah at the Eltham Utley
I mean it really is you need to be happy
alone and yeah like I will be honest
there have been periods where I've dated
like there was a period where I dated no
one for like six months and I just
worked on myself and when I did that
every guy was like crazy about me every
guy because I didn't I wasn't interested
I didn't care I was happy by myself guys
can sense when you don't need one
and and that's when they want you like
every guy wants a woman that like can
handle her own [ __ ] right so I think
that's a that's a good thing to work on
is just like being happy alone it's
being happy alone it's loving yourself
it's knowing you're amazing it's all
those things you surround yourself with
guys and girls that love you that are
your friends and you stop that abut yeah
the girlfriends are never the problem a
great girlfriend of course that's what
I'm saying so go to them like you know
like straight but unless another though
no I give great advices don't take it
right good but here's the thing but I
did date a guy who was 42 okay and on
the first date he was asking me all
these questions that at the time I
thought were crazy cuz I wasn't ready
for a serious relationship
and he was like so what are you looking
for are you are you ready for a
relationship to ever want to get married
do you want to have kids what's your
what are your dream on the first date
that sounds a little creepy I thought it
was yeah I thought it was to an
interview but there was part of me that
was like well I left that date knowing
exactly where he was right and I even
said to him I go Wow no one's ever asked
me these questions on a first date
before and he goes well I'm 42 I'm not
trying to waste time there's not gonna
be a second date if there's no chance
for a future that's a great that's a
that's a great thing but I mean that's a
lot of question it's also like like he's
going through a checklist looking for
the perfect girl right yeah and that I
don't think it's very I guess in a sense
I guess if it's a first date I don't
know I didn't depend on the person and
how weird he was but you're something if
you really want to get to know someone
like there there's a different level of
conversation on the first date where
yeah that's ciao here's somebody who's
who wants a relationship as opposed to
here's someone who just wants like get
wasted and go have sex later well it but
think about it if you get on a dating
website like OkCupid you fill out a huge
survey and it asks you all those
questions so there's nobody reads them
do they I don't know I use it for like
an algorithm right like I'm not sure
what it is yeah they use it to match you
like we're 96% match and then I can go
look at your answers and see where we
differ
right so easy it's the differences you
want kids and I don't for instance
that's a huge one yeah or if the
difference is you do drugs and I don't
like whatever it is I can see that right
away
a so maybe asking all that stuff in the
first date is not so different from from
last night yeah but there's a more
natural way to do it yeah you know I
think it is knowing upfront clarifying
upfront what you're looking for in the
date like are you like ah it's it's an
awkward you know what it's just awkward
right it's just an awkward thing to
bring up I hate it all yeah dating
button stuff but if we're gonna do a
30-day challenge that's a bummer because
because Jen on the way here told me
she'd start fixing me up with one guy a
week and I could stop picking guys go
out with no dates with these guys you
don't know so you take that you get
right to know I forget that yeah you had
me alone and here's the challenge - this
is gonna be part of the challenge - you
have to ask on these dates are you are
you in a relationship are you looking
for a relationship two things you have
to do and what you want yeah like yeah I
don't know if I want a relationship I
just wanna be triggers what I knocked
I'll tell you what I have done I allow I
don't know if I I don't know if I want
to quote a relationship but I do know
this I have realized that if I really
like a guy I can't be casual okay yeah
right how about this how about this you
guys
how about you say on the first date I
just want to be upfront I'm not looking
for anything casual I want to get to
know you good I want to get to know you
doesn't mean does not make you look
desperate it's not that doesn't take any
bravery to say that's a good way to say
it I don't know anything casual
I don't even casual I want to get to
know you that is they want it just be
like we can be friends or right yeah
yeah anything and then and guys will
respect and appreciate that you've been
frank with them yeah and they'll say
okay cool well you know what I just want
to [ __ ] so yeah can we curse and what a
guy yes of course and when a guy says to
me by the way what a guy says to me I
mean apparently I'm doing the sex
cleanse now but well the guy said to me
I just want a [ __ ] in my mind it's easy
for me to go okay this guy just wants to
[ __ ] I won't put I won't attach to him I
won't catch me no no no okay you don't
have that capability I do that no you
don't have that key idea yet veritime
not for long let's not pretend I did it
with people do it with one person do
three now three okay whatever you did it
with like I have a guy tonight look I
have a sex guy I have a sex
okay that I just hit up I called my
service ions and I hit him up and I
don't like him you know why I don't like
him because he doesn't pay for me
when we hang out he doesn't pay for me
which means we're not dating which means
I can have sex with him and feel nothing
well that's great but all right well
after tonight though 30 day challenge
begins tomorrow
no sex I promise it's gonna be very hard
with Halloween yeah it will but yeah I
can do it I can do Halloween a big sex
harder because we're in sunny clothes
does that mean yeah like that's exactly
what she's hey can we I just sighs like
a funny costumes at Halloween it's so
it's so basic like I would rather be a
[ __ ] the other 364 days okay and then do
something funny on when you're going to
a Halloween party that's like a maxim
party or a playboy party you gotta look
hot plate I mean yeah I guess but you
could I mean I it doesn't mean you have
to like take your clothes off you can
look hot anyway you have to pay the guy
you know no no no no [ __ ] no [ __ ]
said thank you thank you goodbye you
know I'm gonna [ __ ] a ghost that's one
of my fantasies to [ __ ] a ghost on
Halloween my costume I've already picked
it out I try to be a [ __ ] uh play
polygamy wife oh nice I'm not gonna get
hit on by anybody I'm gonna doing the
piggy bank and no makeup where are you
going this is great I'll be in San
Francisco oh no that'll be fun yeah oh
come on and it's like that's not sexy
like it's funny I think I have a West
Hollen costume that what is that nobody
will know but I need friends okay what
there is one of the best rap songs ever
is LL Cool J's around the way girl and
he like describes everything about her
girl with extensions in her hair bamboo
earrings a Fendi bag and a bad attitude
baby hair it's like all like yeah lip
gloss is shining I know the lyrics
and then the girls are Pamela wait Lisa
Angela Pamela Renee right right right
like how funny would it it's like why be
Lisa Angela Pamela okay fun and like
everyone wears shirt that says Lisa
Angela Pamela and then we were and then
leo
without anyone telling what you are and
then they would have to guess and like
only those who know the GS of LL Cool J
right would know that that's what your
cost right and then you'd want to hang
out with those yeah and really yeah get
it you get it big get it yeah yeah it's
a great idea I was gonna be at my
costume was creative but you should yeah
why I've been wanting this costume
forever break and never get it like like
you know Pamela angela and renee to do
it i was gonna be a tree that just got
tp'ed so i was gonna be wear like a
brown cat suit and then glue leaves to
it and then put random pieces of toilet
paper on me and be a tree that someone
that's really funny right and then jen
goes you're gonna look like um somebody
trailer's [ __ ] everyday to spinach if
you wear it during the challenge like
well no no try to bandage yeah
definitely
oh there's the plan see that this one's
so fast this was so fun I just I love
having you guys we should do more
all-girls episodes like this like it cuz
it's great um I feel like uh we can wrap
up does anybody want to plug something
plug things area plug something um oh
god
uh I'm gonna be at the Comedy Store on
Saturday that's good that's a thing a
belly room eight okay
I'm hollering perfect I love that Carrie
I have a podcast check it out if you
like white wine and or true-crime we yes
and I'm not plugging anything today
great you should follow Chris Oh social
media has a quarter million borrowers
guys it's kind of a big deal I love the
way you say that it makes her well down
like I'm so cool you are so cool and
definitely watch the PSA Krista and I
just made about [ __ ] who don't love
you and cuddle you and how they can go
[ __ ] themselves you need to check that
out I like it it's really good and I
love you guys follow me at Kate q funny
this is all things comedy this is date
bails poo spy